everything goes in motion and Jon
performs a rebirth ceremony his own
version of a baptism asking Amanda to
give everything to him and deciding her
her first task is a jigsaw disciple to
go kidnap Adam so Adam is kidnapped by
Amanda Dr Gordon is kidnapped by someone
I don't think we actually now and they
are chained up in the dilapidated
bathroom underneath the nerve gas house
before the two contestants wake up John
and Amanda put the finishing touches on
the game with John staging himself as a
dead man in the middle of the floor and
Amanda putting Adam into place in the
bathtub when Adam and Lawrence wake up
they discover the instructions Gordon is
supposed to kill Adam and Adam is simply
meant to escape neither one of them ends
up succeeding but Dr Gordon does
demonstrate his will to survive by
cutting off his foot in order to try to
get away so before he can fully Escape
Jon catches up congratulates him on
Surviving and convinces him to become a
jigsaw Apprentice